hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a british science fiction and
fantasy movie called absolutely anything
the film begins with the launch of a
space probe that carries an inscription
about the human race along with a map to
earth the purpose is for the
extraterrestrials so they can find
humans on earth using the map
the event is broadcasted on tv and
strangely there is a dog watching it
the scene moves showing a man named neil
clark he is being interviewed by the
host at an award show for his
best-selling novel at first everything
goes smoothly but just as he is about to
start his speech suddenly a dog barks at
him which causes the other dogs to bark
and also stomp on him straight away
luckily it was just a dream
meanwhile his dog dennis keeps on
barking until his neighbor fiona gets
mad at him because of this neil
immediately takes his dog out he then
meets with another neighbor named
catherine west turns out she is the
woman who became the host in neil's
dream earlier he also tells the rest of
his dream and actually neil has a crush
on her for a long time but he is too
embarrassed to tell her in person
later he meets rey at school to borrow
some money it is revealed that they are
teachers at the school
in the meantime the space probe is found
by the alien galactic council they are
debating whether to destroy the earth or
make humanity a member of the council as
a test they will give a random human
with limitless power which is the
ability to do absolutely anything
if the human uses the powers for good
then humanity will become a member of
the council but as a consequence if the
powers are used by the human for evil
things the earth will soon be destroyed
the grace period given by the aliens is
10 days
from the results of the meeting the
chosen human is neil who is riding a
bicycle at that time
right after he falls off his bicycle he
acquires the powers unaware
arriving at the school he meets with
headmaster robinson who reprimands him
for being late too often he then comes
to the class where he sees the students
are having fun without the teacher
since he does not want to disturb them
he decides to read the newspaper outside
of class during break time he is having
lunch with ray at the cafeteria
oblivious to his new power neil wishes
for aliens to destroy the classroom of
students hated by him
surely the alien spaceship immediately
kills everyone in that classroom
long story short he returns home while
he still cannot believe what happened
before
funnily enough he orders dennis's poop
to clean itself and of course it happens
strangely feeling confused he chooses to
drink a bottle of whiskey because he
thinks that he was hallucinating
unfortunately he spills his whiskey
bottle therefore he wants the whiskey
back in the bottle while moving his
hands at the same time and it works
now he realizes that he can do anything
by moving his hand
furthermore he wants his dirty whiskey
to be replaced with a new whiskey that
is in the shop but it does not live up
to his expectations the bottle moves on
its own to a nearby shop and breaks the
shop's entrance glass
as a result he is almost caught by the
police but luckily he manages to escape
in the end
back at his house neil suddenly
remembers the previous incident in the
classroom to fix the deaths of his
students he wishes that everyone who
died come back to life
after a while all the dead people rise
as zombies and approach his house
frantically he reverses this and asks
that the explosion never happened which
reverses all his previous wishes he
finally returns to the time when he is
having lunch with rey in the cafeteria
after that neil returns to the class to
check on his students who are still
having fun inside he then wishes that
all his students can be diligent
students
his wish is immediately granted and the
classroom becomes quiet as the students
are excited to learn
later he sees headmaster robinson from
afar he instantaneously moves his hand
to make the headmaster be nice to him
and then he is suddenly praised by the
headmaster as he walks past him in the
staffs room neil unintentionally sees
rey trying to get close to miss pringle
another teacher in the school he then
wishes for her to worship rey who is too
shy to tell pringle that he has liked
her long ago when he gets home he wants
weird things starting from having the
body of albert einstein then having an
athletic body and also he wants
catherine to be in his house
the following day he tells rey about it
and shows some of his powers such as
animating a skeleton growing flowers in
the room instantly making the world's
tastiest sandwiches and always winning
horse races because of that neil's
powers absolutely confuse rey leaving
him speechless
one night the alien spaceship suddenly
malfunctions in order to fix it they
have to take back the power that has
been given to neil for a while
therefore the galactic power fails to
make catherine fall in love with neil
however catherine coincidentally knocks
at his door
after that they spend the night together
and are seen by catherine stalker
ex-boyfriend colonel grant
the next morning the superpowers are
returned to neil
he wakes up and smiles as he remembers
what happened last night he also wishes
the weather outside to be like los
angeles and tells his clothes to get
dressed automatically when he is having
breakfast he wants his dog to be able to
talk like a rational human being not
long after catherine overhears his
conversation with dennis shouting that
he loves neil
thus she thinks that neil has a gay
boyfriend and immediately leaves him
behind
as neil chases after her he runs into a
panicked ray he says that miss pringle
does not love him romantically instead
she worships him as a god
since he is in a hurry he decides to
turn ray into a sausage
he takes the sausage to the bakery where
catherine is
he then tries to explain everything to
her but catherine still cannot believe
him finally neil turns ray back into his
original form
on the other side the aliens do not like
what neil has been doing all this time
because he has not done anything useful
with the superpowers
arriving at her apartment catherine is
very surprised to see grant who was
somehow already at her house
she then locks him inside therefore neil
who sees the incident immediately
invites her to hide in his room
shortly after grant successfully breaks
inside through the window and directly
points his gun at kneel but neil does
not seem afraid of him
using his power he breaks grant's arm
and then fixes it revealing his ability
to grant wishes whenever he says a wish
and makes a hand gesture
on the other hand catherine chooses to
leave the two of them fighting when neal
is off guard grant manages to kidnap him
tying his hand and gagging him to
prevent his escape he also forces neil
to grant some selfish or absurd wishes
such as giving all native english people
huge ears and duck feet while
threatening to shoot dennis
in the meantime catherine looks for neil
in his apartment but instead encounters
rey who is hiding in a closet from miss
pringle's pursuit just at the right time
they managed to arrive at grant's house
and immediately rescue neil who was able
to reverse all of grant's wishes
including miss pringle's now violently
fanatical worship of rey who was close
to being ritually killed by her and the
cult she created beforehand
still catherine and rey decide to leave
him alone because they are already
disappointed in him
soon catherine angrily tells neil that
she will never be able to love anyone
who has the superpowers to control
anything disartan he suddenly has the
idea of using his powers to solve the
world's problems
at first he grants everyone in the world
as much food as they want then says that
war shouldn't happen for any reason
leslie grants every person their own
dream house and wishes for the reversion
of global warming
nevertheless this backfires when
worldwide obesity flares all land is
taken over for houses several countries
declare war for no reason and the planet
falls into a global ice age
because of it neil reverses all these
wishes
feeling depressed with his personal life
and futile attempts to make the world a
better place he attempts suicide but as
he jumps into the river dennis also
jumps in
consequently neil is forced to rescue
the dog including himself afterwards
dennis suddenly says that neil should
give the power to him as he never thinks
of anything selfish he eventually agrees
and does it
meanwhile the aliens decide that earth
is not worthy
it turns out that the galactic council
has a different morality than humans
they see dominance as good in weakness
as evil with neil constantly trying to
end wars and make other people's lives
better is a sign of weakness
they decide to destroy earth using the
doom weapon but at the same time dennis
wishes that the source of power be
destroyed causing the doom weapon to
bounce back to the alien ship killing
them all
with no power left but full of
confidence the next morning neil asks
catherine out on a date which she agrees
to
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching